another star who defies aging is Rob
Lowe at 52 but he might age a little bit
when he gets roasted by Comedy Central
soon and let's face it as cute and nice
as he is he's got a few skeletons in his
closet so is he worried
well Michelle Turner found out when they
had a little chat and of all places a
bedroom as he shot a commercial for his
big brave night the funniest Rossiter's
michelle was a living a dream on the
pink bedroom set surrounded by hundreds
of Rob Lowe I don't know what's
happening I'm mortified the saxophone
playing sweaty that I think I think that
stands the test of time okay Rob walks
into the lion's den on Labor Day am i
stupid to have said yes to it why did
you say yes because I love those roasts
yeah I love them the meaner they are the
more I like it okay and the people who
can take it are my heroes is there
anywhere they can't go part of the fun
of it is that it's it's totally open
season Rob has a ton of famous friends
but it's still a secret who will rub him
onstage there'll be people from my life
who's been important to me
a couple of people that that they're
there why so have you been trapped like
trying at home like all right kids throw
something at me Yeah right give me your
worst come on
my boys are aficionados of the roasts
they love them
you know they're they're 20 and 22
they're like dad you're gonna be killed
now my wife is another I don't even
think she's gonna like some of the
promos I'm shooting well what's gonna
happen are you gonna allow them to be
there yes okay because it's all part of
my master plan because I figure how mean
can they be when my wife
children oh boy educate Oh trust they
will not hold back